Die letzten 24 Stunden waren ziemlich
verrückt. Wir hatten einige neue
Modell-Drops von den größten
KI-Laboren, aber es ist noch nicht
einmal ein ganzer Tag vergangen und wir
haben bereits bahnbrechende KI-News,
über die wir sprechen können.
Beginnen wir mit dem versteckten
Astra-Minor-Modell von OpenAI. Jetzt
eine Pause. Ich habe diesen Modellnamen
nie gewählt, also sag nichts dazu,
aber das Modell wurde im Hilfe-Center
von OpenAI entdeckt und ist Berichten
zufolge sogar besser als GPT-6 Soul,
abgesehen vom Namen. Allerdings hat
OpenAI inzwischen alle Verweise auf
Astra Minor entfernt, aber
möglicherweise wissen wir bereits
einige Informationen über dieses
mysteriöse Modell, die wir heute
aufdecken werden. MiniMax M 3.1 wurde
im offiziellen Modellkatalog von
MiniMax entdeckt und könnte sehr bald
erscheinen. Gleichzeitig tauchte auf
OpenCode und OpenRouter ein neues
Stealth-Modell namens Space Money auf,
ein weiterer seltsamer Name, mit einem
Kontextfenster von 1 Million Token und
multimodaler Unterstützung.
Interessanterweise passt sein Tokenizer
perfekt zu MiniMax M3, auch wenn seine
Leistung bisher eher enttäuschend war.
Kommen wir zu Anthropic: Claude hat
möglicherweise tatsächlich eine neue
wissenschaftliche Entdeckung gemacht.
Rund 950 Claude-Agenten durchsuchten
mehr als 200.000 Enzyme und entdeckten
ein bisher unbekanntes biologisches
System mit Ähnlichkeiten zu den
Mustern, die ursprünglich zu CRISPR
führten. Die Wissenschaftler von
Anthropic überprüften diese
Entdeckung dann in einem echten Labor
und nannten sie Kunst. Wir wissen nicht
genau, was sie bewirkt, aber dies
könnte ein erster Vorgeschmack darauf
sein, wie KI echte wissenschaftliche
Entdeckungen beschleunigt. Apropos
Anthropic: Sonnet 5.5 befindet sich
offenbar bereits im Stealth-Test, aber
Preise und andere Details sickern
bereits durch, die wir heute aufdecken
werden. Anthropic erwog auch, den
Plan-Modus komplett aus dem Plot-Code
zu entfernen und ihn durch eine
einstellbare Aufwandsstufe über Shift
+ Tab zu ersetzen, worüber wir später
sprechen werden. Wir haben außerdem
Informationen zum neuen Spark 1.4,
Xiaomis kommender Memo Version 3.0,
neuen OpenAI-Sprachupdates, einem
weiteren Gemini-Modell, neuen
Meta-Brillen und vielem mehr. Also,
lasst uns einfach mal alles genauer
unter die Lupe nehmen. KI schreibt die
Apps, die ihr nutzt, und die Werbung,
die ihr überspringt. Da blinzelt doch
keiner, oder? Eine E-Mail damit und ihr
seid ein Betrüger. Nehmen wir mal an,
GPT hat das gesponsert. Also, testen
wir es mal. Hier ist der unberührte
erste KI-Entwurf. In Super, ihrem
neuesten Humanizer, fügt ihr ihn ein,
klickt und lasst ihn laufen. Hier ist
das Ergebnis. Dieselbe zentrale Idee,
aber achte auf die Formulierung.
Vergleicht es mit dem Original. Jetzt
Pangram, dieselbe unveränderte Ausgabe
, und das ist die aufgezeichnete
Wiederholung. Mal sehen, was der
Detektor sagt. Da ist es.
Handgeschrieben bewertet dieses
Beispiel als 100%von Menschen
geschrieben. Newsletter,
Kundenentwürfe, Landingpages, kalte
E-Mails, LinkedIn-Posts. Du bist immer
noch der Editor. Du hast das Recht,
zusammen mit der KI zu schreiben.
Stealth GPT.ai ist die beste Wahl.
Fangen wir zunächst mit Astra Minor an
, denn dieses Modell scheint
tatsächlich echt zu sein. Es wurde
direkt im Hilfecenter von OpenAI
entdeckt, und das buchstäblich einen
Tag nach dem Start von GPT-6 Soul. Das
Verrückte ist jedoch, dass Astra Minor
innerhalb der GPT-6-Familie noch höher
angesiedelt zu sein scheint als Soul.
OpenAI hat den Verweis auf Astra Minor
umgehend aus seiner Dokumentation
entfernt. Wir haben ein paar wichtige
Details darüber erfahren. Astra Minor
wurde ausdrücklich als unterstütztes
Hauptmodell aufgeführt, getrennt von
Astra, Soul und Luna. Es unterliegt
außerdem demselben Daybreak
Cyber-Zugriffsframework wie Astra und
verfügt über die standardmäßigen
Daybreak Blue-Schutzmaßnahmen. Bislang
kennen wir noch nicht die Benchmarks,
Preise, das Kontextfenster oder den
Zeitpunkt der tatsächlichen
Markteinführung oder ob sie überhaupt
eingeführt wird. Wir wissen nicht
einmal genau, wofür der Name Minor
steht. Meine derzeitige Theorie ist,
dass es sich hierbei um eine kleinere,
kostengünstigere und effizientere
Version von Astra handeln könnte, die
die große Lücke zwischen GPT-6 Soul
und der Vollversion von Astra schließt
. Das ist im Moment aber nur reine
Spekulation. So oder so sieht das nicht
mehr nach einem zufälligen
Konfigurationsleck aus, denn der Astra
Minor scheint ein echtes OpenAI-Modell
zu sein und gehört zur GPT-6-Familie.
Vielleicht sehen wir das noch in diesem
Monat oder sogar Anfang nächsten
Monats. Tut mir leid, dass ich so ein
bisschen auf die Schliche komme, Leute,
aber wenn ihr es noch nicht getan habt,
dann abonniert bitte den YouTube-Kanal
„World of AI“ und liked dieses
Video, denn das hilft mir wirklich und
hilft mir, jeden Tag mehr Videos zu
machen. Es unterstützt mich wirklich
sehr, daher würde ich mich sehr freuen
, wenn ihr das auch tun könntet.
Minimax M 3.1 wurde im offiziellen
Modellkatalog von Minimax entdeckt und
erscheint damit offensichtlich vor M3
und M 2.7. Interessanterweise hat das
Modell derzeit jedoch keinen
Konfigurationsblock. Es steht nicht auf
der Whitelist und erscheint nicht im
ausgelieferten Code von Minimax, was
stark darauf hindeutet, dass es sich um
eine inszenierte Version handelt, die
aber noch unangekündigt ist. Obwohl
wir es noch nicht wissen oder eine
offizielle Bestätigung haben, sieht es
so aus, als ob Minimax bereit ist,
dieses neue Modell zu veröffentlichen.
Es sollte vielleicht innerhalb der
nächsten 2 Wochen erscheinen.
Außerdem ist gerade ein neues
Stealth-Modell namens SpaceBunny Alpha
auf OpenRouter, OpenCode und vielen
anderen Plattformen aufgetaucht, das
für die nächste Woche komplett
kostenlos ist. Es verfügt über ein
riesiges Kontextfenster von 1 Million
Token mit multimodaler Unterstützung
und ohne Datenspeicherung. Aber hier
wird es interessant. Es gibt immer mehr
Hinweise darauf, dass SpaceBunny
tatsächlich der neue MiniMax M 3.1
sein könnte, denn wenn man auf
Chinesisch dazu aufgefordert wird,
identifiziert sich das Modell Berichten
zufolge als MiniMax-Modell. Und was
noch wichtiger ist, sein Text-Tokenizer
passt perfekt zum MiniMax M3. Der
Bild-Tokenizer ist jedoch anders, was
möglicherweise auf ein verbessertes
multimodales System hindeutet.
Natürlich bestätigt das alles noch
nicht zu 100%, dass SpaceBunny M 3.1
ist. Aber dass M 3.1 gleichzeitig im
Katalog von MiniMax erscheint und
dieses neue Stealth-Modell auftaucht,
ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Eines
möchte ich gleich vorweg sagen. Ich
sage nicht, dass dieses Modell
schrecklich ist, aber in puncto
Webentwicklung kann es mit vielen
anderen Open-Source-Modellen nicht
mithalten. Die Leistung von Space Bunny
war bisher in den Bereichen Physik und
vielen dieser verschiedenen
Webentwicklungstests ziemlich
schrecklich. Denn hier wurde es in
verschiedenen Physikszenen, darunter
eine Explosion, ein Tornado, ein
platzender Ballon und herabfallende
Wassertropfen, gegen GLM 5.3 getestet.
Hier hat GLM 5.3 Space Bunny bei
Newtons Wiege ganz klar geschlagen.
Beide Modelle hatten bei der Simulation
von Wassertropfen und Tornados große
Probleme. Aber egal, Space Bunny ist im
Vergleich zu GLM 5.3, das für all
diese verschiedenen Tests etwa 40 Cent
gekostet hat, derzeit kostenlos. Anhand
dieser Ergebnisse lässt sich jedoch
klar erkennen, dass es hinsichtlich der
Performance eine große Lücke gibt.
Hier beispielsweise scheiterte das
Programm sogar an der
Minecraft-Eingabeaufforderung, was
ziemlich unglücklich ist. Hier werden
fehlerhafte Texturen ausgegeben und es
ist nicht wirklich gut darin, einen
guten Sandbox-Klon des ursprünglichen
Minecraft-Spiels zu formulieren. Und
wenn man Space Money mit Javelin 5.3
vergleicht, hoffe ich wirklich, dass es
sich nicht um das MiniMax-Modell
handelt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
sehr schnell und bietet viele
großartige Verbesserungen bei den
Texteingabeaufforderungen. Ich weiß
nicht, ob das für jeden interessant
ist, aber wenn wir zu Anthropic
wechseln, hat Claude möglicherweise
gerade eine echte wissenschaftliche
Entdeckung gemacht. Das ist ziemlich
abgefahren, und ich fand es wirklich
interessant, weil es eines der
verrücktesten Beispiele dafür ist,
wie KI für echte wissenschaftliche
Forschung eingesetzt wird. Natürlich
haben wir viele Entwicklungen in der
Krebsforschung mit anderen Modellen
gesehen, aber hier hat Anthropic vor
Kurzem ein eigenes modulares
Biologielabor aufgebaut, in dem Claude
mit menschlichen Wissenschaftlern
zusammenarbeitet. Für dieses
Experiment liefen etwa 950
Claude-Agenten 21 Stunden lang parallel
und verwendeten etwa 210 Millionen
Token, um mehr als 200.000 Reverse
Transkriptasen zu durchsuchen. Das sind
Enzyme, die im Wesentlichen RNA in DNA
kopieren. Und hier wird es interessant,
denn Claude wurde nicht ausdrücklich
gesagt, wonach er bei dieser Entdeckung
suchen sollte. Einer der Agenten
bemerkte unabhängig davon ein
seltsames, sich wiederholendes
DNA-Muster, das sich neben einem dieser
Enzyme befand. Das erregte seine
Aufmerksamkeit, weil die Struktur
Ähnlichkeiten mit CRISPR aufwies.
CRISPR ist ein biologisches Muster mit
Arrays, das Wissenschaftler
letztendlich zur
Gen-Editierungstechnologie CRISPR
führte. Claude untersuchte dieses
Muster, verglich es mit bekannten
biologischen Systemen, durchsuchte
vorhandene Forschungsergebnisse und
kennzeichnete es schließlich als
potenziell neues Modell, das von
menschlichen Wissenschaftlern
untersucht werden könnte. Die Forscher
von Anthropic übernahmen dann,
testeten es in einem echten Labor und
bestätigten, dass es sich um ein
bisher nicht charakterisiertes
biologisches System handelt, das
tatsächlich real ist. Daher nannten
sie es ART. Nun ist es wichtig, dass
wir das nicht überbewerten, denn das
ist etwas, das die meisten
KI-Nachrichtenagenturen wie ich am Ende
tun. Aber das ist etwas, von dem wir
immer noch nicht genau wissen, wozu es
tatsächlich in der Lage ist, so wie
ART, und es gibt derzeit keine Beweise
dafür, dass es wie CRISPR zur
Genbearbeitung verwendet werden kann.
Aber die Tatsache, dass KI einen
riesigen biologischen Datensatz
durchsucht, etwas bemerkt hat, das
Menschen zuvor übersehen hatten, eine
Hypothese aufgestellt und dann mit
Wissenschaftlern zusammengearbeitet hat
, ist etwas, woran KI tatsächlich
arbeiten könnte. Das ist natürlich
ein Experiment, aber es ist verrückt
zu sehen, dass KI auf diese Weise
eingesetzt werden kann. Laut Anthropic
würde diese Art von Analyse für einen
Experten normalerweise Wochen oder
sogar Monate dauern. Und jetzt wollen
sie diesen Prozess in der Genomik und
anderen Bereichen der Biologie
wiederholen. Das macht Dario Amodeis
Prognose noch interessanter, denn er
glaubt, dass KI potenziell dazu
beitragen könnte, die meisten
Krankheiten innerhalb der nächsten 5
bis 10 Jahre zu heilen. Er bezeichnet
das Ergebnis allerdings als kaum
möglich und sagt, dass KI im Grunde
jede Phase der biologischen Forschung
beschleunigen müsste. Wie Dario es
ausdrückt, besteht der erste Schritt
darin, zu beweisen, dass KI bei
biologischen Entdeckungen helfen und
diese letztendlich vorantreiben kann.
Claude hat hier natürlich keinen Krebs
geheilt, aber es hat uns
möglicherweise nur einen ersten Blick
in eine Zukunft gewährt, in der KI
definitiv bei diesen Fortschritten
helfen kann. Wenn du die besten
KI-Tools, Workflows und Drops vor allen
anderen haben möchtest, abonniere
meinen kostenlosen Newsletter mit dem
Link in der Beschreibung unten, der
völlig kostenlos ist. Muse Spark 1.4
wurde jetzt im offenen Code entdeckt,
aber es gibt einen wichtigen Haken an
der Sache. Was in Muse Spark 1.4
tatsächlich erscheint, ist der
Mitwirkende, nicht die vollständige
Flaggschiff-Version von Spark 1.4. Das
scheint der gleichen Strategie zu
folgen, die wir bei Spark 1.2 und 1.3
gesehen haben, zu denen ich noch nicht
einmal ein Video gemacht habe. Hier
erscheint jedoch zuerst die günstigere
Contributor-Version, im Austausch
dafür, dass die Daten für das
Training verwendet werden dürfen. Und
im Moment wird diese Statistikseite
fast ohne Verwendung angezeigt, was
darauf hindeutet, dass dies einfach nur
ein frühes Verzeichnisleck vor der
eigentlichen Veröffentlichung sein
könnte. Und das neueste offiziell
angekündigte Modell ist immer noch
Muse Spark 1.3, 1.4 wurde also noch
nicht veröffentlicht. Und das sollte
auch niemanden mit dem mysteriösen
Watermelon-Modell verwirren, das
anscheinend tatsächlich deutlich mehr
Rechenleistung verbraucht. Spark 1.4
sieht eher wie ein inkrementelles
Upgrade aus, während Watermelon
möglicherweise ein viel größeres
Modell ist, auf das wir warten. Wie
auch immer, Meta hat die Dinge dieses
Jahr definitiv ernst genommen und
arbeitet an einem großen Comeback. Als
Nächstes testet Anthropic offenbar
bereits Claude Sonnet 5.5 unter dem
Modellnamen Claude Sonnet 5-5.
Berichten zufolge erhielten einige
Partner nur 24 Stunden lang Zugriff
darauf. Dies geschah offensichtlich
direkt nach der Veröffentlichung von
Opus 5.5. In diesem Blogbeitrag wurde
erklärt, dass Haiku 5.5 und Sonnet 5.5
in den nächsten Wochen erscheinen
werden. Es ist wirklich schön zu sehen
, dass Sonnet oder Anthropic
tatsächlich ihr Wort halten. Die
bisherigen geleakten Spezifikationen
für das Sonnet-Modell sind ziemlich
interessant. Es ist immer noch recht
teuer, das ist also das einzig Traurige
. Berichten zufolge verfügt Sonnet 5.5
jedoch über ein Kontextfenster von 1
Million Token mit bis zu 128.000 Token
an Ausgabe und adaptivem Denken, das
jetzt standardmäßig aktiviert ist.
Eine weitere bemerkenswerte Änderung
ist, dass die erzwungene Verwendung von
Tools offenbar eingestellt wurde, was
darauf schließen lässt, dass
Anthropic möchte, dass das Modell
intelligenter entscheidet, wann Tools
tatsächlich erforderlich sind. Die
Preisgestaltung könnte ein wichtiger
Teil dieser Version sein, denn die
aktuell geleakten Zahlen besagen 2
US-Dollar für 1 Million Input-Token,
10 US-Dollar für 1 Million
Output-Token und nur 20 Cent pro 1
Million Token für Cash-Reads.
Natürlich ist das noch nicht offiziell
, aber der Leaker, den wir hier
vorstellen, ist Light Lyra. Er hat
tatsächlich vor allen anderen über
Opus 1.5 gesprochen und lag mit der
Preisangabe, die am Ende für 1.5
veröffentlicht wurde, tatsächlich
richtig. Und zum Thema Anthropic: Einer
der leitenden Entwickler hinter Claude
Code hat gerade verraten, dass sie
erwägen, den Plan-Modus komplett
abzuschaffen. Stattdessen könnte die
Tastenkombination Umschalt + Tab
verwendet werden, um den Aufwand des
Modells anzupassen. Das Argument ist,
dass die neueren Modelle so
leistungsfähig werden, dass sie
einfach keinen dedizierten
Planungsmodus mehr benötigen. Aber ich
bin ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz
überzeugt davon. Der Plan-Modus ist
nicht unbedingt nur für die Agenten
gedacht. Er ist auch für die Person
nützlich, die ihn verwendet. Ich
verwende es manchmal, wenn ich genau
festlegen möchte, was gebaut werden
soll. Im Grunde kann ich es von einem
Agenten überprüfen lassen oder einen
beliebigen Agenten diesen Ansatz
überprüfen lassen, Änderungen an
meinem eigenen Plan vornehmen, den ich
mit dem Agenten entwickle, und erst
dann kann ich mit der Bearbeitung des
Codes beginnen oder den Agenten daran
arbeiten lassen. Selbst wenn die
Modelle gut genug werden, um intern zu
planen, denke ich immer noch, dass es
sinnvoll ist, einen dedizierten Modus
zu haben, in dem man die KI zunächst
als Planer verwenden und dann einen
Agenten die zweite Einschätzung geben
kann. Ich würde es vorziehen, wenn
sich ein Planungsmodus weiterentwickelt
, anstatt ihn ganz zu verschwinden. Das
ist nur meine Meinung, und das ist
etwas, das viele andere Leute auch
sagen. Als Nächstes kommen ein paar
neue Funktionen, die in Claude Code
eingeführt werden. Hier führt
Anthropic Projekte ein, die ich vor ein
paar Wochen bereits erwähnt habe, die
aber jetzt für Claude Code auf dem
Desktop und im Web verfügbar sind. Im
Grunde genommen fungiert ein Projekt
als eine Konversation, in der Claude
die Arbeit automatisch in mehrere
Threads aufteilen, sie parallel
ausführen und den Kontext zwischen
ihnen austauschen kann. Und sie sogar
weiterarbeiten lassen kann, während
Sie nicht da sind. Sie haben außerdem
lokale Unterstützung hinzugefügt,
sodass diese Threads direkt auf Ihrem
eigenen Rechner ausgeführt werden
können. Sie ist ab heute für
ausgewählte Pro-und Max-Nutzer
verfügbar, eine breitere Einführung
folgt in Kürze. Und Claude Code Cloud
Sessions sind jetzt auch offiziell als
Research Preview verfügbar. Das
bedeutet, dass Sie mit dem
Programmieren von Aufgaben in der Cloud
beginnen können und Claude auch dann
weiterarbeiten kann, wenn Ihr Laptop
zugeklappt ist. Da alles auf der
Infrastruktur von Anthropic läuft,
sind Cloud-Sessions in den Pro-und
Max-Plänen enthalten und Anthropic
gewährt bestehenden Abonnenten
außerdem ein einmaliges Bonusguthaben
von 100 $ für Pro-Pläne und 250 $
für Max-Pläne. Dieses Guthaben kann
zunächst aufgebraucht werden, bevor es
wieder in Ihren normalen Tarif
einfließt. Anschließend können Sie
Cloud-Sessions über das Web, Ihr Handy
, Ihren Desktop oder direkt über die
Befehlszeilenschnittstelle starten.
Wenn Ihnen dieses Video gefällt und
Sie den Kanal unterstützen möchten,
können Sie über die Option „Super
Thanks“ unten für meinen Kanal
spenden. Oder Sie können unserem
privaten Discord-Server beitreten, wo
Sie monatlich kostenlos auf mehrere
Abonnements für verschiedene KI-Tools
zugreifen können, sowie tägliche
KI-News und exklusive Inhalte und
vieles mehr. Ich weiß, wir alle wissen
, dass Kimi K 3.1 recht bald erscheinen
wird, aber es sieht so aus, als ob es
jetzt tatsächlich bestätigt wurde,
denn die Community hat entdeckt, dass
Kimis Online-Konfiguration mit diesem
neuen Kimi K 3.1-Agenten-Routingmodell
aktualisiert wurde und es bereits in
der Liste der verfügbaren Modelle
angezeigt wird. Die Konfigurationen
umfassen die Denkmodi „Low“, „
High“ und „Max“ mit dem riesigen
Kontextfenster von 1 Million Token und
der fortgesetzten Unterstützung für
Swarm. Dies geschieht auch nur wenige
Tage, nachdem Kimi 3.1 in diesem
mysteriösen Pi-Post angekündigt hat.
Obwohl 3.1 noch nicht offiziell
veröffentlicht wurde, scheint es, als
stünde die Veröffentlichung kurz
bevor. Als Nächstes ändert Xiaomi
bereits die zugrunde liegende
Architektur für Mimo Version 3.0, und
wir haben gerade Version 2.6
vorgestellt. Es sieht so aus, als ob
das Team bereits an der Architektur
für diese neue 3.0-Familie arbeitet,
um sie für lang laufende KI-Agenten
effizienter zu machen. Der Grund dafür
ist im Grunde, dass der Kontext von
KI-Agenten ständig wächst, was ihren
Betrieb immer teurer macht. Diese neue
Architektur löst dieses Problem, indem
sie den KV-Cache zwischen Ebenen
gemeinsam nutzt und wiederverwendet.
Dabei geht sie intelligent mit den
vorherigen Token um, die tatsächlich
für die Spannung benötigt werden. Die
Ergebnisse sind ziemlich beeindruckend,
denn bei einem Kontextfenster von 1
Million Token verwendet sie etwa
fünfmal weniger Prefill-Flops und
einen 4,5-mal kleineren KV-Cache als
die Mimo-Version 2.6, während sie
gleichzeitig den Abruf langer Kontexte
verbessert. Im Wesentlichen sollte
diese neue Architektur für die Version
3.0 umfangreiche Kontext-und lang
andauernde Agentenaufgaben viel
schneller und effizienter verarbeiten.
Bei einem Wechsel zu OpenAI hat die
ChatGPT-Sprachfunktion heute ein
umfangreiches Upgrade erhalten. Die
Sprachfunktion kann jetzt Ihre
verbundenen Apps wie E-Mail, Kalender
und Slack verwenden und kann von den
GPT-6-Modellen Astra, Sol und Luna
unterstützt werden. Das wahrscheinlich
größte Update ist jedoch, dass die
Sprachfunktion jetzt mit ChatGPT
zusammenarbeiten kann. Das bedeutet,
dass Sie buchstäblich mit ChatGPT
sprechen und es Dokumente,
Präsentationen, Websites,
Tabellenkalkulationen erstellen oder
sogar komplexe Browseraufgaben für Sie
erledigen lassen können. Dieses Modell
wird derzeit weltweit eingeführt und
verwandelt im Grunde genommen die
Sprachsteuerung von etwas, mit dem man
einfach nur sprechen kann, in etwas,
das tatsächlich Maßnahmen für einen
ergreifen kann, damit man seine Arbeit
erledigen kann. Google hat zwei neue
Modelle vorgestellt, Gemini 3.8/TTS und
Gemini 3.8 Flashlight TTS, die laut
Google die bislang ausdrucksstärksten
Modelle für die Audiogenerierung sind.
Diese Modelle wurden entwickelt, um
eine viel natürlichere und
ausdrucksstärkere Sprache für Dinge
wie KI-Unterstützung, Erzählungen,
Podcasts oder andere Sprachanwendungen
zu generieren. Beide Modelle sind über
die Gemini API und Google AI Studio
verfügbar, wobei Flash das
leistungsstärkere Modell ist und
Flashlight eine leichtere und
kostengünstigere Option bietet. Zu
guter Letzt hat Meta heute etwas
ziemlich Einzigartiges vorgestellt.
Hierbei geht es zwar nicht zu 100%um KI
, aber es handelt sich um einige neue
Produkte, die auf den Markt gebracht
wurden und bei denen KI mit dem
eigentlichen Produkt selbst verknüpft
ist. Heute haben sie nämlich diese
beeindruckende neue VR-Brille
vorgestellt, die nur etwa 100 g wiegt,
also ungefähr so viel wie ein
Kartenspiel. Meta behauptet, dass dies
das beste Anzeigesystem ist, das das
Unternehmen jemals entwickelt hat. Im
Wesentlichen vereint es Kino, Computer
und Spielekonsole in einer Brille, die
von einem KI-System gesteuert wird. Man
erhält riesige virtuelle Bildschirme,
vollständige 3 D-Umgebungen und sogar
DisplayPort über USB-C. Leute, die sie
ausprobiert haben, sagten, dass es sich
wirklich so anfühlte, als hätte man
einen Computer im Gesicht. Eine Demo
deutete an, dass man mithilfe
virtueller Arbeitsbereiche sogar einen
ganzen Film bearbeiten kann. Auch Metas
KI-Strategie wird immer interessanter,
denn laut Zuckerberg verschenkt Muse
riesige Mengen an Token, Berichten
zufolge etwa 100 Millionen Token pro
Woche, zusammen mit dem Zugang zu einer
virtuellen Maschine. Die größere Idee
scheint darin zu bestehen, KI-Agenten
dazu zu bringen, Nutzern tatsächlich
bei der Durchführung von Geschäften
und Transaktionen zu helfen. Dabei
könnte Meta möglicherweise mit
Transaktionsgebühren Geld verdienen,
anstatt sich nur auf Abonnements zu
verlassen. Wenn Meta diese Brille
tatsächlich mit leistungsfähigen
persönlichen KI-Agenten kombiniert,
könnte die Interaktion mit einem
Computer völlig anders werden. Ehrlich
gesagt, das war definitiv ein
unglaublicher Tag im Bereich der KI. Es
passiert noch viel mehr. Um auf dem
Laufenden zu bleiben, solltet ihr euch
unbedingt ein paar dieser verschiedenen
Bereiche ansehen, wie zum Beispiel
unsere Schul-Community. Dort könnt ihr
natürlich immer über alle Neuigkeiten
aus der Welt der KI auf dem Laufenden
bleiben. Außerdem erhaltet ihr jeden
Monat Zugriff auf kostenlose KI-Tools
und viele weitere Vorteile. Außerdem
könnt ihr frühzeitig auf KI-Modelle
zugreifen. Schaut euch auch die Welt
der KI von Coding Platform und
Benchmark an. Werft einen Blick auf den
Newsletter, werdet Teil des
Discord-Kanals, folgt mir auf Twitter
und schaut euch schließlich unseren
zweiten Kanal an. Tritt der
Twitter-Seite bei und folge mir auf dem
YouTube-Kanal. Abonniert unbedingt
unseren Kanal, aktiviert die
Benachrichtigungsglocke, gebt diesem
Video ein „Gefällt mir“ und schaut
euch auch unsere vorherigen Videos an,
um über die aktuellsten Cydia-News auf
dem Laufenden zu bleiben. In diesem
Sinne wünsche ich euch allen einen
wunderschönen Tag, verbreitet
Positivität und ich sehe euch ganz
bald wieder. Ich glaube, ich habe es
vermasselt, euch alles zu zeigen. Bis
später, Leute.